قنابل صوتيه وعيارات مطاطيه في زبيد شام
شماليه كوسوف
هذا منتهى اليه تجمع لمحتجين صرب غاضبين
في محيط مبنى البلدي يرفضون نتائج
انتخابات قاطعوها وافضت الى فوز رئيس
بلديه الباني حاصروا عربات الشرطه
الكوسفيه مطالبين بمغادرتها ورفعوا عليها
رايات صربيا دون ان يثنيهم عن ذلك
الانتشار الكبير لقوه حفظ السلام
انت قلق على عناصرك ونحن قلقون على اهلنا
عليكم ازاله عربات شرطه كوسوفو من هنا نحن
نصدقكم ويمكنكم البقاء وسنتظاهر سلميا اذا
بقيتم وحدكم
رفضت التراجع عن اجراءاتها رغم الاذانات
الدوليه مؤكده حاجه المجتمعات المحليه الى
تقديم الخدمات البلديه اما صربيا التي لا
تعترف بكوسوفو دوله فتطالب بانشاء اتحاد
للبلديات السلبيه في المناطق التي تقطنها
اغلبيه من هذه القوميه داخل كوسوفو وتعتبر
الوضع الراهن مدعاه لوضع جيشها في حاله
تاهب لحمايتهم
رئيس الجمهوريه هو قائد القوات المسلحه
بحسب الدستور اصدر امرا بوضع الجيش في
اعلى درجات الجهوزيه العسكريه كما اصدر
رئيس اركان الجيش تعليمات اضافيه بنشر
وحدات الجيش في مناطق محدده وفقا للخطط
الدفاعيه والاستراتيجيه هذه التوترات
الجديده تاتي بعد اشهر من مفاوضات رعاها
الاتحاد الاوروبي ودعمتها الولايات
المتحده للاتفاق على مسار لتطبيع العلاقات
بين كوسوفو وصربيا مسار لا يصل الى حد
الاعتراف المتبادل لكنه يسهل التعاملات
اليوميه بين المجتمعات المتجاوره وهو كما
تثبت الاحداث الراهنه لم ينتقل بعد الى
حيز الفعل
يتمسك الطرفان بموقفيهما حتى الان رغم
المناشدات الدوليه فحكومه برشتينا تعتبر
تنصيب رؤساء البلديات الجدد واجبا دستوريا
بينما تراه بالجراد تعديا على الاقليه
الصربيه وان كانت قوه كيفورد تحاول منع
انزلاق التوتر الى صدامات دمويه فان
السؤال يبقى مطروحا حول تطبيق العلاقات
بين الجانبين محمد المدهون الجزيره من
بلده الشماليه كوسوفو